say juan barclay
i love the necklace 26 that's nice
you're looking good and this guy all
year long chris sims has been on the
saquon barkley bandwagon from the get-go
even before the season he knew you were
going to be great and you proved him
right yep thanks for that man but i
didn't it wasn't like it didn't take me
to be a rocket scientist i mean i
watched you coming out in the draft you
were special can i touch your legs can i
just
say quad barkley sorry i actually lost
that line i got a man crush on him i had
to feel it those are some of the most
impressive legs ever i mean obviously
you were born with them but like how
many how many times a week do you lift
legs uh during the season during off
season um all season probably a lot more
than uh during the season right um i
think during the season we for my
position we do three lifts um and i
think one or two of them is lower body
um but in all season uh you attack lower
body a lot more and yeah uh you like you
said i was born with them i was born
with the cavs i always had like big
calves right growing up i ain't i wasn't
tall i was always short with big calves
and um when i like turned like 15 16 uh
i went to like my high school coach and
said i want to play college football
i won't do this i'm going to do that
what i got to do
he said get your butt in the weight room
and i just started grinding and uh i
guess i hit it at the same time around
puberty and i guess i just got lucky and
my leg just you know they're barry
sanders-ish yeah that's you know that's
so crazy because when i got to provo um
emma smith came up to me like grabbed my
legs and said i wasn't the only guy
grabbed me ladies he was like well then
he's like you got like barry sanders
legs and i'm just like wow like because
i'm a big fan of barry sanders and ever
smith and um you know all the pass backs
and the great backs and um to get that
comparison is everything yeah you know
the running back position in recent
years has been devalued in the nfl
you're at the front end i think of what
will be a comeback and a re-embrace of
it what drew you to the running back
position as a kid um i always loved it
um you know it's just i had fun running
away from people and uh making people
miss uh even when it wasn't football we
played a game when i was younger called
manhunt and manhunt i used to too yeah
and i was just always really good at it
and um shocker
then i moved uh to where i when i where
i was raised and when i grew up and i
was playing with one of my friends and a
couple my friends and they were like wow
you're really good you should join our
little league team and
my dad signed me for hockey football and
i remember we used to have to walk to
practice every single day um and he
always give me that looking practice and
every time the ball would touch my hand
i just i don't know it's like uplifting
i just had fun doing it and i just fell
in love with the bishop you guys know
manhunt you know man no it's like team
tag it's like a team hide-and-seek game
but like a neighborhood in a
neighborhood
yeah right yeah you would be the worst
player to play against that yeah
has dad come to terms with the fact that
you're a giant not a jet is he is he
okay a year later yeah he's okay he was
okay right after um it was crazy how
close uh the picks were um and growing
up i was a jets fan too and uh my dad's
a die-hard jets fan he got a jets tattoo
on him
but i i'm probably hopefully try to get
a bet that if i do something or we do
something as a team uh he'll get a giant
tattoo on him too where do you land on
the cj anderson thick or fat uh
conversation
um
man how do i answer that one uh thick or
fat thick okay go with that let's go
fake um you know cj anderson uh what
he's doing uh his story his story line
uh this year is amazing
for being cut and now to being one of
the reasons why they were able to push
into the super bowl and had a great run
in late year later in the year in the
playoffs man i love his story and happy
for him yeah
he recently said that if you got a
problem with him being thick or fat
we'll take it outside and we've been
asking guys this week based upon your
time in the nfl is there a guy that
you've come across that you would not
want to run into in a dark alley
somewhere um
i mean calais campbell i think that was
i think that would have to be the the
first answer yeah um
uh the first time i played him he just
phys he's just a giant he's just a giant
like and then his voice just takes over
the top the way he's the way he's
yeah exactly um so i would say i'll say
uh coleas campbell claire's campbell
definitely would be uh one that uh you
probably uh i mean i don't back that
from nobody to be honest but you
probably wouldn't you know want to seen
it back in an alley yeah how about your
your year it was amazing uh i do think
you should win rookie of the year
without a doubt but you had so many
highlight plays what was the one play
where you were just like you were even
proud of yourself is there one that
stands out above the rest they gotta be
the first one the first one you gotta be
the first one because for me the jaguars
you're talking about the long 68 yard
touchdown right against the jaguars um
to do it against that defense and um to
break the tackles the way i did in that
on that run uh for me in the preseason i
only had one game against cleveland um
and i kind of messed with my hand a
little bit so that was like my first
real game i only had like two series in
the cleveland game so i really didn't
play in the nfl yet and you know
uh i was able to solidify what i
believed in myself and what i was able
to do and once i did that that just gave
me the confidence um that you know i
could do it's college it's you know it's
obviously not college but it's just it's
football at the end of days football and
um sometimes you catch yourself getting
caught uh and oh he's not gonna be able
to do this he ain't not he's not gonna
be able to do that and then you wonder
and then you kind of look at yourself
but um that just solidified everything
and just knew that i believed in myself
and i was going to be able to do this
and hopefully i can do this at a high
level for many years ago yeah so no one
cares about people's fantasy teams i
don't care about mike's fantasy team i
don't care about chris's fantasy team
but the game against the titans that was
fantasy playoffs i'll give you this
opportunity to apologize for that who
own you and fans yeah i'll let you guys
down yeah unless you got john yeah i
didn't i listen it wasn't me but i'm
giving you the opportunity for everyone
out there yeah
which camera should i look at i look at
the camera yeah whichever one i
sincerely apologize um i'll let you guys
down there um it won't happen again next
year um but i'm probably one of the
reasons why
you got it
right yeah that's why you were in the
playoffs because you had me that's right
and you know you got a piece of hardware
irrespective of any fantasy
accomplishments anyone may have had
pepsi rookie of the year saquon barkley
congratulations and there were some
great rookies this year yeah and uh for
you to win that uh great great to hear
and congratulations yeah thank you um
it's amazing um to you know first like i
say thank you to the fans because the
fans vote you in
and to be you know mentioned with those
great rookies like you said uh we had
seven pro bowlers this year uh the most
since 1993. um and then when you look at
the names of philip lindsay his story
what he'd been through a baker mayfield
what he did for cleveland this year um
and for me to be able to win that award
um and put on my pepsi blue today um
just just means everything giant blue
looks good john's blue pepsi blue we got
like something blue we got sam's blue
i wouldn't say that we got some
highlights of you and we kind of just
want you to kind of talk through them
and just kind of what is going through
your brain at the moment and like let's
have fun with it all right let's do it
so right here we got a screen
right now i'm just trying to make
something happen
will hits me uh somehow somewhere i keep
my balance uh look at look at shep down
there blocking down the field my wife
seemed to do a great job blocking down
the field um upset right now i didn't
score
get up look it's only 25 tackles so you
should be upset this one
what
what whoa
that's insane uh that's the first time i
jumped off of two feet um to do a hurdle
so uh that was something new um my mom
definitely not a fan of that
you ever tried that move and have it not
work uh
actually nah i think i've been really
successful so far i've been successful
so far i have a theory that that move
hurtling guys people do it now more
often because
they know that they won't get hit in the
head as much as like in the past you
won't when you get in the air it's not
as dangerous as it used to be yeah
your knees at it yeah right oh yeah and
you a lot of people think that it's
dangerous but when you jump a lot of
people don't expect you to jump so
that's why they pause and that's why
when you coming down you see a lot of
people get hit and they land on their
feet right or they just they don't take
a hard hit at all because when you jump
in a game everyone's like trying to
tackle you and they're looking at your
hips then you jump and the people to the
right or the left of them and just like
and then they react a little bit later
so
it's never it's really so far for me it
hasn't been bad um but you know
obviously seeing a couple of those
highlights it's been fun it was a fun
year um i had a blast i learned a lot um
and hopefully i can make some more
highlights for you guys in the future
what kind of junk oh sorry guys i said
what kind of dunks can you do i mean
like can you be like could you get an
nba dunk competition and i wouldn't say
i could actually um i'm not really like
a fancy dunker right um i'm i'm not
gonna put no flash to it i'm more like i
would say the i'm not i'm a
russell westbrook was like i was going
to say like it would be like uh how i
would be able to dunk in a game uh when
i play with my friends um but russell
westbrook is russell westbrook so that's
not the right comparison at all but more
that type of style just a powerful
dunker um just you know going up and
down yeah challenging you see if you
jump with me right um have fun with that
would you believe me if i said i touched
him once
yeah i would hope so because i haven't
hey sequin 16 games this year you
started every one we had over 2 000
yards from scrimmage how does the body
feel after going through something like
that for the first time you know body
feels great um one thing i am proud of
myself and i'm gonna take a little bit
of credit uh that i listen to all the
vets and to all the guys that gave me
advice and uh they were saying that i
waited till year five i waited to year
four to start taking care of my body and
i was just talking to my team and i'm
just like why not do it now why not
start as early as you can
so i took a little bit during the season
but i was able to get myself a team um
that was a pt a massage a
acupuncture and all that uh just keeping
my body right so um god thank thank god
also with luck too
just felt healthy all year
and obviously you get some bruises and
some bangs but i was able to keep up
with those and
hopefully i can keep continuing to grow
on my routine uh in the future and learn
from this year and what i can do
so a
team or sorry a guy that's going a
little under the radar for the draft
coming up in a couple months is your
former teammate trace mcsorley sell me
on him real quick the elevator pitch
trace mcsorley is a leader and a
quarterback it's just real simple
competitor competitor competitive
competitor i know i sound like jake
james franklin when i'm saying no
but yeah he's a competitor um and that's
at the end of the day
i'd rather take a guy
obviously i believe he's talented but
just because you're talented doesn't
mean you're going to make it in nfl and
that's something that i've learned um
you know that's why a lot of guys who
are talented they come in and they don't
succeed they don't do as great as they
should because they don't have that that
that that competitive nature in them and
i was saying yesterday no matter what if
you're down by 30 points or you're up by
30 points or you're 2 and 14 or you're
uh 14 and two whatever your record is
trace missile is never going to change
yeah and i've seen that firsthand and um
i i went to war with him and football
multiple times and i was always ride for
him whether you never know he could end
up on the giants one day or um if he
goes to wherever team he goes soon okay
all right we got a little fish ball i
mean i got so many questions i could ask
you but these are off the cuff here i
mean so you're just gonna dig your hand
in there
and uh one of those is just chris gets
to touch her legs again
i'll take it
it's actually all of them so what fear
do i have what fear do you have i don't
like spiders i know that that's like i
don't even want to be around that we got
a rap what fear do i have i would say
i mean i think i can go oh easy text
text
some like it's like from where i'm from
like uh like some of my friends like to
go like paintballing and like all right
trails and like one time i got a tick on
me and it just scarred me for life and
like and like i had it on a second time
and like maybe it was my mind playing
games with me but at one time thought i
saw a tick
on like my shoulder and like it wasn't
on my body right on like my clothing and
i remember just taking all my clothes
off like pretty much getting
butt naked in front of my family and
i was like i'm never wearing that again
and just threw it away but it's like
just ticks like you can't like step on
them like you gotta use fire yeah like
if they get inside your skin you might
have to take them out yeah downside to
having big legs more surface area for
ticks
all right we're going to take a break
thank you saquon congratulations again
we'll be back with more pfc live or that
for this appreciate you guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports